[Music]
mr. Raymond you've been called the king
of the keyhole shows
I like to think of myself as the king of
the glamour shows to the future
would you say everything you touch turns
to go not everything but enough my
name's Paul Raymond welcome to my world
of erotica please do come along you
shall be disappointed
this is an opportunity for some rewrite
the cultural history it's not Germany
so we'll just mr. Raymond would you say
your work is degrading to women no was
she nice she was just a girl mr. England
can give for their dishes he's got
children one day you'll run the business
be a respectable business
can't think of too many other people who
have the relationship that we have she
gonna do this get the good stuff would
you describe him as a good father he's
my best friend really just want a normal
life normal life is for normal people
wait until I tell W what I dad's really
like
don't cheat death under the against
[Music]
[Music]
think of one person who'd say say has
never had a whack of iterator all right
they meet another person Gandhi
[Music]